it has been 1500 years since the fall of
our four bears
and valicia has been slowly dying
ever since
[Music]
almost further now but we're in the
middle of the deadlands the blinds of
the splice dry and in Old trees no birds
and no matching
Darkness spreads as day gives way to
Twilight
the mother's flame now all but a flicker
live
blessing of the crystals
the crystals work their magic through us
you have been blessed Joshua but who
shall claim their fading light the grand
duchy of Rosaria Bastion of tradition at
the very least we must secure Drake's
breath the holy Empire of San Brek
where ambition is divine the Imperial
Banner shall fly over every city in
storm
all shall bow before their enemy The
dalmekian Republic whose fortunes shift
with the desert sands
and what if our wise wrong
goaded into
it in chaos it might reap the iron
Kingdom forged in faith and fear their
souls were sullied with this stain of
ether
I merely cleansed them of their
corruption oh the kingdom of wulud
indomitable in its isolation the dark
swallows more of the realm with each
passing day and as the fringes fade the
people flock to the mother crystals from
a single spark will the land ignite
in the year 860.
the Imperial Army will March upon
Rosario
and from the slaughter shall a new
Shadow rise
fall upon the dominance
painting their Destinies black as
nightability to summon beasts of great
light should command respect but instead
has left us outcasts
and so I became their puppet
what makes them think they have the
right to use us to leave us to die when
our bodies are spent I'll crush him
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]